-You know our next guest
from her work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and such films
as "Sisters" and "Wine Country."
You can see her and Mo Willems
in "The Storytime
All-Stars Present:
Don't Let the Pigeon
Do Storytime,"
which is streaming now
on HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the sho
our very good friend
Rachel Dratch.
-Hi, Seth.
-Hi, Rach, how are you?
-Hi, good. How are you?
-Good. It has been far too lon
since I've seen you.
And it is always just a deligh
to lay eyes on your face.
-And you too, though I was tol
to look up at the lens.
-Yeah, if you ever feel
the need to just, like,
take a little peek down.
-Give a little glance at you
-Let's each take a little glance
right now, ready? Here we go
Ooh.
-Aw, hi, Seth.
And back to
the screen dot, okay.
-I was really happy.
The last time I saw you
doing something live,
you appeared on "SNL."
There was a little return
of Debbie Downer.
And Debbie Downer was,
like, ahead of the curve
as far as how bad
things were going to get.
-Well, kind of 'cause --
so, everything was so bad then
that, like, a lot of
my friends are like,
"Oh, you should do
Debbie Downer."
so then Lorne let us
do a Debbie Downer,
And I came in with,
like, a big mask,
and it was like...
[ Laughs ]
And then, like,
that was a Saturday.
And then literally
like three days later
the whole world shut down.
That's how fast
everything happened.
And then I was kind of like,
"This isn't funny."
So, anyway, but at the time,
you know,
there was a lot of tension
afoot and all that, so yes
-We forgot that Debbie is one of
the overlooked
horsemen of the apocalypse
[ Laughter ]
-I think so.
-When she shows up,
bad things happen.
-Debbie's got her finger
on the pulse of
all bad [bleep] --
stuff happening.
-Yeah, I like that
the bat signal for Debbie is
"things are so bad,
we think we can throw
a sketch together for her.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly. Exactly.
And now it just writes itsel
every day.
-Yeah, exactly.
Everybody says Donald Trum
sketches write themselves.
Really, I would argue Debbie
Downer are the ones that are -
-For sure.
-What was the last --
I know you are a great supporter
of the theater and Broadway.
What was the last thing
you saw live?
-The last thing I saw live -
I saw the musical
"West Side Story."
Oh, also Poehler and I
went and saw Hall & Oates
'cause I was on a --
I was on a big retro,
like, you know,
high school music thing.
-Where did you see Hall & Oates?
-At Madison Square Garden
with Squeeze.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
I mean, you --
I mean, you guys have always
presented as the Hall & Oate
of comedy, you and Poehler
-I think Poehler's not gonna
like it that I'm, you know
saying that Hall & Oates
was the last concert she saw
-Oh, yeah. You think she wants
something cooler out there
-She wants something edgier,
you know.
No offense to Hall & Oates
-We should say that after that
she went down to the
East Village and saw some, like,
death metal --
Nordic death metal band.
-Yes, Nordic death metal,
that's cool.
-You went home but she went out.
-I went home
and had some tea, yes.
-Eli -- I cannot believe
your son Eli is 10.
-Just turned 10, yes.
-So you, like many parents
are having to usher his wa
through Zoom school, I'm sure?
-Yes.
So we had, you know --
like everyone,
we had a big chunk of that
in the spring,
and it wasn't easy,
like everyone says.
But I got to the point
where, like, you know,
his homework became my homework.
So I'd be like, "Oh, no,
we have to do math today."
And then, like, he would get
these extra art assignments,
which just made my heart sin
because it's like,
he's not gonna be cutting
a cereal box to make a basket.
Like, I'm gonna be doing that.
So I really started to dread
all of the extra art project
'cause I'm not that good
at that.
-Do you think that
Eli is aware of that?
And that, you know, there's a --
it's contagious that your drea
then transfers to him?
Or would he have
dreaded it anyway?
-No, I think we have mutual --
you know, we are a mutual --
we'd pass the hot potato o
meltdowns, school meltdowns.
-[ Laughs ]
-Sometimes it was me,
sometimes it was him, yeah
-I know one thing that
you have used to maybe
avoid the meltdowns
is video games.
I think this is something that
you are allowing Eli
to partake in. How's that going?
-Right, okay, so, last yea
I had a pretty good system down.
I was like, "You can't pla
video games during the week,
during school week,"
and I was pretty proud of myself
'cause for the most part
he stuck to it,
but then all this happened
Then that all went out
the window.
And he became very into
"Fortnite," which I didn't know.
I just want to like --
moms of young kids, like,
if you can avoid "Fortnite
at all costs,
it is like heroin to kids.
-[ Laughs ]
-So it has a lot of
addictive qualities.
At first I was just
opposed to the guns.
Then the guns just become
secondary to the addiction to it
'cause it, like,
keeps them on it.
So we've had a lot of conflict
about trying to tear him away.
But it's, like, also the way
that they talk to each other
He can talk to his friends
so it became a social thing.
-That's sort of
how you're justifying it.
It's the socialization.
-Yeah. Exactly. Yes.
-It's like, yeah, my --
you know, I don't want my kids
to take heroin, but that's
how they see their friends
[ Laughter ]
-When you put it like that
it doesn't sound so good.
But yes, that's basically
what it's come down to.
And now he plays a lot.
-It seems so long ago now,
but when this first started,
some of my first guests,
after we shut it all down,
were Poehler and Maya,
and we were talking about
the talent show.
I know sort of the "SNL" women
of that era,
your kids did
a Zoom talent show.
Is Eli --
Does he have characters?
-Well, he does, but what
happened was Abel just wrote u
a sketch
and handed him a script.
Abel is Amy's son.
Abel wrote a political sketch.
I think Eli was playing
Elizabeth Warren.
And Abel was -- shoot, I forge
who Abel was playing,
but it was a guy.
But, anyways, so they did
some political comedy.
-Gotcha. How was it?
-And meanwhile Ana's son
did magic,
and Maya's kids had some, like
sort of fencing,
sword fight thing.
Anyway. And Tina's daughte
did gymnastics.
So a lot of different talent
happening.
-Yeah, that's a very --
I mean, that's, like,
bang for your buck-wise, if yo
can get fencing and gymnastics
and sort of like trenchant
political commentary,
that's a really good show.
-Yeah, that's not happenin
anywhere else on the Internet.
-I think Mo Willems --
if you have kids,
you know exactly who that is
And if you don't,
you wouldn't have any reason to.
But he's a wonderful
storybook author.
And you did a live performance
of his show.
Was that -- And this is, again
in front of a live audienc
before the world
turned upside down.
Was it so much fun?
-It was a lot of fun.
-Yeah.
Did you -- Did Eli come?
I feel like that would be
friendly to a --
-I know. He didn't come.
-Why not?
-I don't know. He didn't fee
like -- It was in D.C.
-Oh, okay, that's fair.
-He didn't want to
take the trip.
Then I wish he'd been there,
yeah, okay.
-I mean, you would think,
you know,
for a kid
who does political comedy,
he'd like a trip
to the nation's capital.
-I know. He would. Well, maybe
he'll have to watch it, yeah
-I'm sure when you were gone
he didn't take advantage
of his video games.
-Probably, yeah.